Layout includes help reduce
code duplication quite a bit.
But for more targeted land adaptations
we can get even more fine-grained.
Using all those resource
qualifiers we learned about,
we can vary everything from
number of columns to heights and
widths to margins and
spacing and beyond.
Let's take a look.
You could use the w600dp qualifier
to variant integer resource.
Changing the number of
columns in a grid of items.
An integer resource is basically
a number with no units like pixels or
dp or anything like that.
On a phone,
you could have one column, which is
basically the same as a vertical list.
And on a tablet or
with the w600dp qualifier,
we could bump it up to three columns.
This approach works for
both grid view and
the grid based layout managers
bundled with recycler view.
When switching from a list
type presentation to a grid,
you'll likely want to use
a different layout for each item.
To do this,
you can access your column count integer
resource from code in your adapter.
And use that to decide
which layout to inflate.
It's worth noting that in
addition to integer resources,
there are also Boolean resources.
So you could have a Boolean like multi
column, which defaults to false,
but in w600dp gets set to true.
And then you could decide to use a tile
versus a card type presentation.
Another super powerful technique is
to just vary specific metrics like
paddings, margins, or
even button widths and heights.
Here's our same UI, but this time
we're defining the tool bar and
content view once.
And specifying height and margins
that change on a 600dp wide screen.
This technique is really,
really powerful and
let's you minimize code
duplication quite a bit.
Here's another example.
A full width button on a phone
might get too wide past 400dp.
So you can create a dimension
resource called button_width,
that's match_parent on phone, and
exactly 400dp once the screen was this
larger using the w400dp qualifier.
Note that simply typing match_parent
won't work in dimension resources
because it's a special value,
-1, that doesn't have any units.
Here's a quick trick that
works around that limitation.
Just put this item tag
in your dimensions file
that's equivalent to
the integer value -1.
Then you can reference it in
other dimension values like so,
using @dimen/match_parent.
And hey,
remember key lines from Lesson 3?
On smaller devices the standard
keylines are 16dp and
72dp, but once you get to larger sizes
you can start using the standard
tablet keylines of 24dp and 80dp.
This too can be done with
varying dimension resources.
In this example we're
telling the toolbar
to inset the title from
the left edge of the screen.
To the second key line.
So we're going to inset by 72 or
80dp, depending on which
device we're running on.